hello my name is Anita Naren turneth I
am from Michigan Tech in the beautiful
Upper Peninsula of Michigan and I am
going to talk about nonlinear dynamics
of evaporating liquid films
now this is a fundamental fluid physics
problem that's received a lot of
attention in the last 30 years or so and
the attention is kind of dying down now
since people figure that they've
understood everything about it somehow I
feel that this problem is a gift that
keeps giving there's a lot more to
explore and this presentation is really
how I used nd solve mathematical nd
solve for partial differential equations
to solve a particularly transient
nonlinear stiff partial differential
equation and how Mathematica and Andy
solve made my life a little easier in
this process so very briefly a little
bit about where I come from and why I'm
doing this and so on
so Michigan Peck as we call it is in the
lovely Upper Peninsula of Michigan we
have a very good engineering program
that focuses on multiple trajectories of
engineering and science I am primarily
in the thermal fluid sciences area so
Michigan Tech is in this little town
called Houghton Michigan which has two
well seasons winter is coming and winter
is here in fact winter is going to be
here in about two weeks for as it starts
end of October and keep snowing until
the middle of May so this this is what
my campus looks like from my office
window so it's it's beautiful it's
really beautiful both seasons really
fantastic right over here out of
interest this little bridge is called
the Portage lift bridge which apparently
is the world's heaviest and widest
double deck vertical lift bridge and I
found it in a book called thousand
places to see in the United States and
Canada before you die so hat was very
interesting when I saw that this is the
only Brits that is a land connection
between something called the qivana
County and the Halton County I live in
the qivana County so I really need to
time myself with the bridge and boats
going under the bridge or I am late to
work or I miss my flight so it's quite
an interesting place to live in so
diving right into the topic I will first
set the stage with a video of
experimental results that our colleagues
at the University of Washington Seattle
put together some of you may actually
recognize what this is quite immediately
so what is going on in this video
is I have a liquid film or they had a
liquid film on hot solid substrate
now what this hot solid substrate did
was it started evaporating that liquid
film and because of a certain
combination of effects instabilities in
the liquid film manifest on the surface
such as hexagonal structures a lot of
you may recognize this as being the
rayleigh bernard convection cell and
rayleigh bernard structures which is
what it is what is interesting is that
there is a pattern formation at a
pattern selection that is keenly coupled
between the liquid film the properties
of the liquid film and the substrate in
question you have some very clean
hexagonal or polygonal structures that
form at this stage this film is about
three millimeters to begin with and it
starts evaporating so it starts
decreasing now this kind of a polygonal
structure is known as a short wavelength
instability a short wavelength
instability essentially says that the
distance between cell centers is short
as compared to the entire domain that we
are looking at so as we keep proceeding
with the evaporation of the liquid film
you will notice the timestamp and the
thickness stamp at the bottom left
eventually the liquid film hits a magic
thickness about a millimeter or so for
this particular problem where it
transitions from something called a
short wavelength instability to a long
wavelength instability now we have a
vernacular structure as it is called
because it looks like vermicelli and
then we are getting to that point where
the transition starts and now this is
called a long wavelength instability
where the instability wavelength if it
were captured appropriately through
experiments is equivalent or comparable
to the domain this is about five inches
across the domain is about five inches
across is what you must understand what
is important and critical here as that
as this liquid film keeps evaporating
eventually holes open up in the film
surface when holes open up in the film
surface those holes you know expose this
substrate to very high heat fluxes
because you don't have any more liquid
on it and that can be very very damaging
to the substrate particularly if you
don't want the substrate overheating so
the what I did was use nd salt to
actually simulate these long wavelength
in stable
which were right at the end of that
video right so I'm looking at long
wavelength instabilities which may be
solve by numerically of course through
this nonlinear con Hillier type equation
which seems to be quite varied in what
it can be used for for instance this
could be used this equation variance of
this equation with certain boundary
conditions which I won't necessarily get
into here can be used for gravity driven
lava flow soap and tear films herbivore
and plant dynamics what I am interested
in is liquid film dynamics so that
nonlinear equation with the F and G take
up certain well shapes and forms
depending on what the forces are that
you'd like to capture that effect this
liquid film so I'm going to solve this
nonlinear differential equation with
periodic boundary conditions it is it
has a temporal evolution term so the
initial condition is some sort of a sine
wave essentially what I'm saying is my
liquid film is on a hot solid substrate
and I've disturbed it so it has a sine
wave and it evolves from there right so
you solve this doesn't take very long in
Mathematica with the nd solve function
and as I manipulate this is my liquid
film surface a bit of an undulation as I
progress in time you will find that this
film starts contorting starts contouring
and eventually forms dry spots of the
substrate so why does this occur this
occurs because the liquid film the
surface of the liquid film is under the
effect of certain forces the important
forces that affect the dynamics are that
ensure that a certain solution is
eventually available surface tension and
gravity which act to stabilize any
undulations or any perturbations on the
liquid film and there is an effect
called thermo capillarity which is how
surface tension changes with temperature
which acts to destabilize the liquid
film so thermo capillarity is the
culprit that destabilizes the liquid
film and it is in a continuous battle
against surface tension and gravity
which try to disabuse try to stabilize
the liquid film and straighten it out
and this is the balance for a certain
kind of film and temperature conditions
so liquid film liquid properties and
temperature conditions you
film rupture as its called which can be
deleterious to the substrate because now
you have very high heat fluxes showing
up in the dry spots and it was also
interesting and this was something we
published a while ago that you when you
start with I'm looking at discrete
Fourier transform energy so to speak
right now and what we see is that we
start with a sine wave and these the
sine wave energy kind of distributes
itself into higher frequencies as well
what is interesting to note it's
irrespective of the initial conditions
we choose for a particular liquid you
know fluid properties and a surface
coupling we always recover the same
maximizing wavelength we always recover
the same maximizing wavelength which is
very interesting because that can be a
design parameter for us particularly if
we wish to design something like an
evaporative cooling technology which has
liquid films in it is a kind of a design
parameter for us so in the next few
slides what I will be looking at
prominently certain variants of this
nonlinear con Hillier type equation all
of which have been validated against
literature and experimental data one of
the main things is that we chose to use
nd solve as against say a traditional
computational fluid dynamics approach
because nd solve and Mathematica allowed
us a certain flexibility in adding and
dropping nonlinear terms in a nonlinear
differential equation that usually
traditional computational fluid dynamics
does not quite allow you traditional
reputation for dynamics if we were to
get bogged down with it then we'd have
to start thinking about okay now I need
a moving mesh between my interface my
liquid interface and its vapour how do I
do that I didn't necessarily actually I
did not have to do that explicitly here
so from here on certain examples all of
which have been published of course so
the first example I have is something
called a pendant drop this is some this
is perhaps one of the most intuitive
cases to understand so for the pendant
drop I would actually like you to
imagine a liquid film on the ceiling so
something like a paint film right so I
understand paint is not necessarily
Newtonian and so on but if you have a
paint film on the ceiling you do know
that it starts making
drops which are shaped like pendants and
hence it's called a pendant drop and
this is what the simulation does again
less than a couple of seconds is all it
takes for a highly third order nonlinear
differential equation with periodic
boundary conditions and when I look at
the animation I see that my initial film
starts contorting form something called
the pendant drop over there and on the
other end over here it forms something
called a satellite drop or a secondary
drop it is also of course interesting
and perhaps obvious when I increase my
domain size I see multiple panel drops
right so it is quite obvious that Oh
useful keystroke you see multiple
pendant drops and satellite drops at
Shaw now why this was particularly
interesting to us was this was the first
case we solved using ante solve and we
compared it with experimental results
for dichloromethane silicon oil and a
couple of other fluids we also compared
it with certain linear stability
analysis and it checked out perfectly
well which gave us a lot of confidence
in continuing to use and dissolve in
Mathematica for these interfacial flow
problems so the next problem I am
looking at next variant of this problem
is a liquid film that is under the
stabilizing effect of surface tension
and gravity which always ensure that the
film is stretched and flattened out and
the destabilizing effect of thermo
capillarity which really contours the
film that's what it does so again the
und solved with periodic boundary
conditions what we've done as I
mentioned is we added an extra term to
roughly the previous equation now we've
got surface tension gravity and thermal
capillarity and you kind of understand
how the song goes
every nonlinear effect we need we just
need to slap onto it another term
simplistically speaking of course
because you need to figure out what that
term looks like which can be done using
a lubrication approximation on the
navier-stokes equation that is a bit of
a project on its own but as solving this
equation itself although it looks quite
difficult doesn't seem to be that
difficult for nd solve this takes a
couple of seconds and what you're going
to see are structures that are similar
to what I previously showed except that
the physics at work is a little
different we have surface tension
gravity and thermo capillarity forming
something called a finger structure
because it looks like a knuckle or a
finger
now these are called thermo capillary
fingering structures and on either side
of this primary finger you have
secondary fingers what is also
interesting or what is actually
published in literature is they have a
name for this process this process is
called a touchdown process only because
the liquid film eventually touches down
at the hot solid substrate and perhaps
exposes the substrate if it dries out
completely so this was a little about
how you could use and dissolve to study
this fundamental problem in fluid
physics of interfacial instabilities now
what we did next was interesting this is
what we wanted to do this was this was
all by the way in terrestrial gravity
essentially speaking my liquid films in
these cases were all on earth what if we
turned gravity off what happens if you
turn gravity off or in other words what
if gravity is not as important anymore
not necessarily the gravity is being
turned off it just is not as important
as stuff is surface tension and term of
capillarity and you can doctor it to be
so depending on the fluid properties and
so on so that is exactly what we did we
got rid of gravity so we essentially got
rid of the gravity term in our evolution
equation because it's it captures
temporal evolution solve it using nd
solve again obviously and initially it
wasn't all that interesting because the
dynamics were pretty much as we I had
shown in the previous slide you know you
have thermo capillary finger structures
primary structures and secondary
structures that form okay so what off it
you turn gravity off right so something
must have happened something interesting
should have happened so we did see that
there was something interesting that
indeed did happen so when we take a look
at both the cases the base case that had
gravity and the zero gravity case
obviously we notice that the zero
gravity case proceeds at a much more
accelerated rate it is accelerated as
compared to the base case so so if you
have a situation where gravity is not as
important as surface tension and thermo
capillarity for a liquid film non
evaporating in this case you can be
almost pretty sure that in this case
your film is going to rupture and expose
your substrate at an earlier time now if
you're looking into evaporative cooling
technologies perhaps that is not a good
thing
but if you actually are looking to
deposit a pattern in this fashion very
quickly maybe that
good thing so if you want to use it to
your advantage or curtail these dynamics
if you wish so to use it to your
advantage or to curtail these dynamics
you would need to know how you could
control this evolution so there have
been certain strategies that have been
proposed in literature such as the
radiation of the film and there couple
more which don't strike me immediately
what we looked at instead is actually a
porous substrate so our liquid film has
been on hot substrate or a hot plate for
so long for all these simulations what
with that and this hot plate was solid
there were no holes punched into it now
we are going to look at a porous
substrate and this porosity at least for
the sake of this presentation here is
modeled very simply it's something
called Darcy flow it is very linear flow
it is pressure driven it's a very very
very simple case a simple case however
can still be very informative as what we
realized so to enact this porous
substrate we had to add an extra term to
the nonlinear evolution equation this
this actually this material has not yet
quite been published and when we look at
the evolution of a liquid film in
terrestrial gravity with the porous
substrate as one would imagine the
porosity acts to drain the liquid film
of course I'm also assuming in my
mathematical model that there is no
limit to the depth of my substrate which
may not be realistic and so on but it is
still quite informative to begin with so
that's what happens when you have a
porous substrate which is isothermal in
this case it's maintained at a constant
temperature so this is nice but it
depleted my liquid film maybe I don't
want to deplete the liquid film maybe I
want to hang on to some of the
structures prominently too because here
they just go down quite significantly so
how am I supposed to do that in this
case now I turn gravity off right I turn
gravity off with my porous substrate
notice that the code takes a few more
extra seconds to run because what we
realize is that when we have a liquid
film under the effect of surface tension
gravity
thermo Capital actually no gravity
excute is the surface tension thermo
capillarity and a porous substrate we
actually did find with our very simple
porosity model that we have this
contracting liquid film which loses its
secondary structures and sticks around
these primary structures stick around
for on
long time duration as compared to all
our previous simulations so that's
something porosity we you know may just
be a control parameter that we can play
with if we are looking through deposit
patterns are generally to control some
aspect of interfacial dynamics we don't
quite entirely understand it at the
moment because there's more to porosity
than a simple linear model you have to
consider multi-directional properties of
a porous substrate which we have not and
those could play an important effect in
determining what the liquid film
dynamics could be eventually so that was
a little about all these cases three
cases which I looked at one I call the
base case so that poster estriol gravity
and solid substrate then we have zero
gravity and a solid substrate and zero
gravity with a porous substrate so I
wish to compare all these three in a
single animation to see if there is any
difference in how these this dynamics
the space your temporal evolution
progresses all right so when I look at
my three cases what you will let me just
go back we have all three cases to begin
with initially the zero gravity case
with the non porous substrate is leading
the pack it is the fastest to evolve it
is the fastest to move towards rupture
in this case rupture is the exposure of
your substrate the next closest is the
zero gravity case with a porous
substrate and the slowest of the lot is
actually the base case so it has to rest
really gravity acting on it and it has a
non porous substrate however as I
continue with my evolution I find that
okay the zero gravity case has ruptured
so if I'm looking at evaporative cooling
technologies oh that's bad
but however there is a switcheroo of
sorts between my base case which was on
a non porous substrate with my zero
gravity case which was on a porous
substrate now the base case with the non
porous substrate has switched its
leading the dynamics is what's going on
so there was a certain deceleration of
dynamics induced by porosity at an
eventual time which we still of course
need to study using different means and
eventually we find that even the non
porous substrate ruptures and the porous
substrate from zero gravity however does
not rupture we see some sort of an in
and finger structure and it persists in
this timeframe that I am looking at so
that tells me a little more about the
fact that okay there is of course some
non-linearity that maybe is going on for
all I know and the polar substrate seems
to have an effect on curtailing maybe
some of the instabilities and you see
that these structures remain for a while
so what I look at next is exploring film
dynamics perhaps maybe a little more
quantitatively in in in effect I'm
trying to move towards a quantitative
method of looking at some dynamics and
I'm looking at recurrence plots what
exactly is a recurrence plot now a lot
of you may of course know of it but this
was something I only recognized and
realized only recently so it was
published by Marwan at all a couple of
years ago and they talked about a
recurrence plot around Rp being a square
matrix that reveals all the times when a
phase space trajectory of a dynamical
system roughly is in the same area so as
an example I have an example from
Mathematica help file a nonlinear
differential equation that shows some
sort of an oscillatory behavior I look
at a TFT power spectrum and now the
recurrence plot is far more vivid than a
discrete Fourier transform it shows me
some sort of a tessellated floral
structure every time you see an x marks
the spot kind of a deal it just means
that you are revisiting a particular
point in your trajectory so I thought
why not use this recurrence plot to look
at my space your temporal film dynamics
because there is a certain periodicity
to it we've got wavelengths and so on
going on over here so that is what I do
I look at my film dynamics with zero
gravity and a porous substrate and I see
okay let me just pause this a little
that's roughly speaking the initial
condition where I have an x marks the
spot you know and as I keep proceeding
in my film dynamics eventually I see the
formation of some sort of an incipient
thermo capillary finger structure that
shows up as a bit of a floral pattern on
my recurrence plot and I keep going on
because I know that when I have a porous
substrate
part of this structure is going to get
damped so this recurrence plus plot
should close because multiple states
would be recurring between something
like minus 20 and 20 on the x-axis so
that that is pretty much in fact what
happens I have an occlusion I have a
closure of the RP on the right that
shows me how the the trajectory the
dynamics of this problem so it's an
interesting way of looking at the
problem dynamics I received a lot of
help in actually doing this recurrence
plot from the Mathematica stack exchange
side because the initial recurrence plot
algorithm I wrote was extremely clunky
and they out tweak it for me in fact so
that was very nice of them so now I will
move to the next slide where I look at
the comparison of film dynamics using
recurrence plots for all cases I have a
base case which was terrestrial gravity
non porous substrate a zero gravity case
with a non porous substrate and a zero
gravity case with a porous substrate to
see what the deal is when I look at all
of them like that so initially they all
have the same initial condition they
start evolving so what's going on over
here is I have the base case on the Left
which was the result some of the
numerical results were published in 95 I
have the zero gravity case in the center
and the zero gravity case with porosity
on the right hand side so from the film
dynamics initially I had realized that
the zero gravity case is the one that
approaches rupture first so it should
form these floral patterns and floral
structures before the rest of them and
that turns out to be true so we have the
formation of a floral pattern and then
we have the case with the porosity and
zero gravity and then the base case but
then the base case and the zero gravity
case takeover and rupture with multiple
secondary structures and a primary
structure and so on
while when I introduce a porous
substrate that seems to arrest this
progression of events so this gives me
for the confidence that perhaps this is
a nice tool eventually to look at film
dynamics because of the spatial temporal
evolution that I have so that's a little
about that what do I have next okay
that's not very good but we will see
what that does so then I look at a
linear stability analysis of my
nonlinear differential equation why
do a linear stability analysis so that I
can uncover the most destructive
wavelength for a certain set of fluid
thermo physical properties I would like
to know what the most destructive
wavelength is because perhaps I want to
design a system that does not attain it
if somehow if I'm able to design this
system right so I look at the growth
rate of long wavelength instabilities
because this is what I'm simulating long
wavelength instabilities essentially a
positive growth rate tells me that for a
certain set of properties I do have
these thermo capillary structures what
have you forming and that may not be
something I'm looking at so maybe I'd
want to tweak my fluid or change my
fluid for whatever I'm working for so
perhaps I want a higher surface tension
to decrease the growth rate of non these
long wave instabilities perhaps I want
porous substrate that further damps
these long wavelength instabilities
perhaps I want to have a film that is
thick enough so that gravity is
important and really removes the long
wavelength instabilities so it's a nice
predictive tool to have to see what
exactly is going on with certain fluid
parameter so that you can pick the right
fluid for a certain problem that you're
trying to do could be either curtailing
these structures or perhaps laying down
patterns in a manufacturing process with
a certain fidelity that you want so
that's interesting
so in conclusion of course there's a
realization that I have that there are
multitude there's a multitude of
nonlinear dynamics an interfacial fluids
which are heated on a substrate for
instance and these are all coupled and
this is something that perhaps I need to
study a little more there could be
control strategies through a porous
substrate true through the introduction
of a porous substrate but I still may
need to include multi-dimensional
effects in the porous substrate at the
moment I don't quite know how but that
of course is why we do research perhaps
in the future I can look at the effect
of evaporation I did once look at the
effect of evaporation but it was nothing
particularly special all evaporation did
was based on the evaporation rate it
either depleted your film completely or
it just made your thermo capillary
structures a little higher in amplitude
maybe I need to use certain analytical
methods a similarity solution through a
solid on theory perturbation methods to
see what goes on after that so that's a
little
very brief conclusion of course to
capture my thoughts on this problem
because I'd like to thank a lot of
people who are part of this project
really for me of course that the first
three are faculty members at Michigan
Technological University and the
University of Washington at Seattle the
multitude of users of Mathematica who
helped me out through Mathematica Stack
Exchange and definitely my wife and the
plenty of cats that I have they all play
a major role in it and that is pretty
much I think my presentation because
that's just an initialization cell that
I have and yeah thank you for listening
and it was great to be here at Duvall
from conference 2016
[Applause]